So one of the things we hear in the modern world we could say
It really is a modern phenomena is this idea that there's somehow something weird about rituals that you know
You hear it in that we want things to be informal. We want things to be natural and that somehow
rituals are
artificial we have this idea, you know you everybody has heard some
Christian come up to them and try to convert them and say something like you know
What I believe isn't a religion what I believe it's a relationship right? I don't like religion
I want a I'm spiritual but not religious
I want a relationship with God or a relationship with the universe, but I but this whole idea of
ritual and and and liturgy all of this is is somehow
inauthentic you could say and that there's this kind of raw authenticity that we can get to and
So hopefully we can look at that and I'm going to try to show you guys that in fact, yeah rituals are inevitable
This is Jonathan Pageau, welcome to the symbolic world
So before we start I just want to tell you guys that this month I have recorded the 3rd of the patron only videos it
is an interpretation of Rumplestiltskin and
and
It's it's it's a wonderful story
It's actually one of the stories I find that has that shows really
This the problem of the end of something and how it turns into the beginning. It's related to credit to borrowing
All right
So in terms of this problem of ritual now
One of the reasons why people seem to think that is that there really is a there really is this idea of like a pure
This idea of like pure unadulterated
relationship right this idea of pure connection this notion that you know, you can be
And that is related to being informal until we get this idea that somehow
intimacy is
Informal that that you know to be able to to to walk around in your underwear
And your belly out that if you're if you can do that with someone it means that oh, yeah, that's real intimacy
You know, it's like the more and for who you get the more the more that that's that that's intimacy
But that's not that that is that's a strange misunderstanding of how human relationships work. In fact human interaction is
inevitably ritualistic and
We need to understand that way if you want a way to understand it to simply
Try the opposite right try to do the opposite of how usual
Human relationships work and you'll notice just how ritualized our behavior is, you know?
I've given the example before the people that you know, if you think that that you are not constantly engaging in ritual behavior
Try this right try just staring at someone for like three minutes non-stop
And see what happens, you know that person would come extremely uneasy right try
try to
You know, I don't try to if you're as you're talking to someone try top starting to pick your nose
Let's say and see see what happens as you're talking to them with your finger up your nose, right?
We don't realize to what extent are our
Intern human interactions are coded and our ritualized
You know when you speak to someone you look at you look at them in the eye
But you don't look at them in the eye for too long
You look at them in the eye. Then you kind of look somewhere else. You look at them in the eye. There's this rhythm of
Looking there's also a rhythm of exchange, you know
you you have to say something for a little while and then stop and then let the other person speak and
there's a there's a there's a kind of dancing that appears in our
Relationship that rhythm you know is a ritualized
reality
There are all kinds of other rituals that we have we say hello. We shake people's hands
We you know, you don't speak to someone if you're you don't stand behind someone in order to speak to them
You stand in front of them in order to speak with them and the thing that's interesting is that I know I can already hear
Some of the arguments that people will have is to say something like: yeah, of course. Yeah. Okay. We have these social standard these social
Manners in which to interact but they're natural like they're they're they're based on reality, right?
So if you if you stand behind someone and you speak to them then they won't hear you as well
They won't be able to see your facial expression
And so and that's why we stand in front of people and you know
It's like it's normal to extend your hand to someone shaking someone's hand
You know, it's it's related to it a gesture of goodwill
It's showing that you don't have something in your hand like a knife or something that you could hurt them with
You know saying hello is the same, you know, you put your hands out you're showing that you're not there to hurt them
It's like all of these are
Meaningful and they're related to to to reality and so the answer is of course, that's true
of course, it's true that all these many rituals the ritual of looking the ritual of this this
rhythm of speech, you know also the the the
Even the question of space between people there's that there's a certain different cultures have different amount of space that you're allowed to be in
Depending on who you're with and although it changes with cultures
There is a universal reality which is that there are different
Spaces in which you can be in relation to someone depending on your level of familiarity with them, you know
all of this is analogous to
Sacred space to sacred rhythms in terms of of chanting in terms of precession. All of these are the same and what's funny
especially for the argument saying that these rituals are
Natural or that they they're meaningful
It's like well, so are the religious rituals, right?
You know in a church the actions that you pose are related to the reality that you're facing so
Everything we do in church is not arbitrary. It's not arbitrary rituals
The rituals are really are exactly the same kind of rituals that you have an interaction with
Your your friend or with a stranger and so when we're in church, we do things like bow
We bow before God bow before something which is higher than us and what that is is acknowledging
Your position regarding someone else but we do that even then once ourselves, right?
We bow our head like men, you know, so you see someone you bow your head
What do you think you're doing when you're doing that you're saying I'm not putting myself above you
I'm recognizing I'm bowing my head to you. I'm
recognizing you as
I'm kind of putting myself under you to a certain extent but it ended up being being if the other person does the same it
Ends up saying like we're together
But in church, we bow to God
We also bow to the priest and the priest bow to us and then we do things like kneeling all of these
All of these making yourself lower is in relationship to something to elevate something higher
You know
We do things like we do the sign of the Cross like if you're you're bothered by the sign of the Cross
But you're not bothered by hello. It's like why does this why did the sign of the Cross?
Why is that strange that as you are engaging in something sacred you would make a gesture with your hand?
But it's not strange that if you're engaging with another person, you're gonna get your you're making a gesture with your hand
It's like there's nothing strange about either one of them they're just there
They're just manners and their natural manners like that the sign of the Cross. I mean I can go in
I don't want to go into the symbolism of the sign of the Cross
But maybe I make a video about that. The sign of the Cross is completely coherent in terms of centering yourself
placing yourself in relationship to to God but also
Bringing gathering your gathering your yourself. Let's say into your into your heart. We can go into that later, but
It's the same for all the rituals and you know, like I've talked to you about this before this idea of standing together
Looking in the same direction
all looking at at
At the altar all looking to that sacred space at the same time singing at the same time reciting at the same time
You know, that's a very powerful thing to say words with other people at the same time. What do you think that does?
It's not arbitrary
It's a manner to bring ourselves together into the same vision into the same into the same line confessing things together
All of that is completely coherent
and
than
You know and then ultimately communion itself. The ritualized eating is
Is a hyperversion of all of us sitting around the table
eating from the same food and
all the you know that this idea that if you're able to sit around a table with your family and everybody speaks in turn and
Everybody is respectful of the other person and everybody is also leaving food for the others
All of these are ritualized
behaviors that we totally understand and you only know that that you can only realize that it's ritualized behavior when you have someone who does
The opposite if you have someone who comes to your house and his arrogant and is and is a jerk and sits at the table
And and just starts grabbing things putting them on their plate, you know starts eating with their mouths open, you know
it's talking while they're eating and this is and is being
Arrogant is taking up all the room and not letting other people speak
You'll realize just how ritualized when you are in a proper dinner is and so
communion where we all come together to the same cup to the same table and we eat and drink together right in our
Desire to be united in to Christ. It's the same as the not the same
It's like I said
It's it's a million times more but it's the same structure as you gathering around the table with your family and eating together
in a manner in which to show your unity not to show but to participate in your unity as a family so
It's very important and another aspect which is important to understand is clothing. For example
and so one of the things that you hear, you know, especially in certain
kind of non-denominational Christian
Context is that none are like, you know, they would never want their person in front to be wearing a
Vestment to be wearing a you know, like Oh, who does he think he is?
I know he's trying to separate himself from the others
He's trying to wear this thing that separates him knows the pastor just dresses like everybody else, you know
He wears a shirt and ripped jeans and you know
he's got his hair kind of messy and sits on the side of the stage and it's like do you think that that's not a
Ritualized behavior. Do you think that do do you think that rebellion? It doesn't have a pattern
Rebellion has a pattern
Informality also has a pattern even even as you move towards the informal
It's part of the meta-pattern just like that's why I keep talking to you guys about monsters and death and all of this
It's all part of the meta pattern. And so if you if you if you think that being informal isn't doesn't have a
Structure it totally has a structure, you know, because we recognize someone who is acting informal. We recognize them right away
I keep joking about how it's like I can recognize a punk from a mile away, you know
And he's being a rebel, but he's following those rules
He's following that
he's following the pattern of what it means to be a rebel what it means to be a punk and so to sit on the
Stage with a ripped shirt and without with a t-shirt and ripped jeans is also ritualized behavior
The question is what is it patterning? Like what reality is it Patterning? Is it is it patterning something
Which is there it depends why you're in church
Like are you in church to worship God are you in church to recognize that?
There's something above you then we're all going to gather together in
Reverence and in honor of the thing which is above us in order to you know
Unify us is if that's what you're doing then maybe
Wearing ripped jeans tshirt and sitting on the side of the stage and and having your hair all messy. Maybe that is not
Symbolizing that. Maybe the ritual you're engaging in is not the right ritual, you know
But it's still a ritual
You can't avoid it and what like I said if you are a pastor and you're the center of attention and everybody's looking at you
What you do and what you wear is going to be meaningful by the very fact that you are the center of attention
You cannot avoid it you cannot avoid
Manifesting meaning if you are the person towards which everybody is turned now
The question is what are what meaning are you manifesting?
What ritual are you participating in what you know?
What pattern are you engaged with? If you engage in a pattern which tries to negate
the reality of what you're doing
Which is that everybody's there everybody's there and everybody's looking at you because you're in the front
You're the one who's supposed to interpret the Bible or tell; speak the Word of God
But you want to act in a manner which denies that
It's a it's a it's a kind of schizophrenia. It's a kind of...
What it would the worst thing that it's not always but the worst thing that can happen is that you are actually
elicidating that in people like you are going to be just like the rock star also has everybody's attention
but then their behavior as everybody patterns their behavior on the rock star is to to elicit you know, the
Let's say that the lower side of our patterns we could call them in felt the more libidinal
the more libidinal dancing the more libidinal patterns rather than matter than a walls rather than something which is which is which is
beautiful and elegant and
You know which manifests how the world can fit together. So anyways
I'm really hoping that that is a little hint at how
Rituals are inevitable. I hope you enjoyed it and
All right guys, I will see you again soon
If you enjoy the symbolic world content, there's a lot of things you can do to help us out
Why not subscribe, please do go ahead and share this to all your friends. You can get involved in the discussion
We have a Facebook group in which people can talk about these subjects
I will put all those links in the description. And also if you can please support us financially by going to my website www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com